chez nous
salut à tous au début l'être humain se
met à marcher puis à courir certains
l'oublier mais pas le mouvement sportif
des sportifs de haut niveau et pour nous
en parler raymond fontaine alors ta
passion c'est quoi raymond bas
évidemment là pour ça y est c'est parti
après 15 ans d'un crétinisme 22
sélections en équipe de france lui fois
champion de france ou encore champion du
monde 98 de course de montagne
aujourd'hui raymond fontaine est un
maillon fort de son club
bonjour tout le monde
et bien
c'est venu avec les causes des écoles
en urss
milieu scolaire ça fonctionnait plus que
pas mal au niveau du cross-country après
il ya eu l'arrivée des changes a pris à
notre éducateur sur petite île au niveau
du cospi qui était employé au niveau de
la mairie
le kospi est une grande famille de
plusieurs générations simplement
convivial ce club rassemble
tout
deux fois par semaine ces jeunes de 5 à
10 ans sous la pluie et parfois le
soleil apprennent les bases de
l'athlétisme sous le regard avisé des
éducateurs est en tout cas aller
regarder ils ont l'air de bien s'amuser
et c'est cet homme toujours passionné
qui est à l'origine de cette école
d'athlétisme à 72 ans chaque jour il
fait grandir ses enfants
allez c'est parti
comment ça se fait j'aurais que ce club
soit un club formateur qui autant
d'enfants bah c'est à dire que nous on a
une politique quand même du club des
jeunes parce que c'est sûr chez nous on
a la catégorie des grands ou
actuellement on a beaucoup de coureurs
au stade mais chez les jeunes dont on
essaye d'avoir le maximum de jeunes les
motiver pour qu'il reste ce site c'est
ça ce qui est important c'est on essaie
de garder cet esprit jusqu'au temps que
ça dure normal pas à 2 you entend
une énergie qui fait que ce club compte
cinq entraîneurs deux salariés une
dizaine de dirigeants pour 200 licenciés
j'ai appris que là les tice et l'école
du sport en général parce qu'il ya
dans l'apprentissage ya le croise déjà
que c'est dans le cross que l'enfant
pourra courir
hélas les titres on touche pas qu'un
seul que nous sommes tous à plusieurs
donc au niveau motricité
apprentissage
alors qui sait qu'à gagner
moi j'aime m'entraîner dp6 jusqu'à 16
ans donc ça fait quatre ans j'ai fait 3e
bénévoles et maintenant ma prière depuis
quatre ans je travaille au québec
genou